- [Mark] Hi, there.
- Hi, how are you?
- Hey, how are you?
- [Mark] Good, how are you?
What's your name?
- Jamie, what's yours?
- - [Mark] My name is Mark.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Mark] So, what's going on?
- [Jamie] I swallow, I fuck in the ass,
I a freak, I do anything.
And I don't pose here and play games.
- [Mark] Really.
- [Jamie] Yes.
(Mark chuckles)
- [Mark] You wanna make
a little bit of money?
- Yes, I do.
- [Mark] I don't know if I'm interested
in that list of five things, but-
- Okay, I'm just kidding,
about having (indistinct).
- But, I'd like to get your photograph.
- Okay, that's fine.
- [Mark] My studio's
right around the corner.
- Okay.
- Hop in.
- All right.
- [Mark] So, tell me,
what's your name again.
- Jamie.
- [Mark] Jamie. Jamie, where
are you from originally?
- Long Beach.
- [Mark] Long Beach.
- I was raised in Long Beach.
I mean born in Long Beach.
Raised up in Las Vegas till
when I was 3 till I was 13.
- [Mark] Oh, so you really
grew up in Vegas then.
- Yeah, I did.
- [Mark] And then how long
have you been here on Skid Row?
- Since 13 until I'm 34 now.
- [Mark] You've been here a long time.
- Yeah, I have.
- [Mark] How'd you get here at 13?
- My mom broke up with her husband
and she found a new husband
and they either could've moved
to the cold weather, she
didn't wanna move there,
so my mom found her new
husband at a church.
And they raised me, he was a great dad,
but he was an alcoholic.
She didn't want to be
back east with his family,
that's too cold for her.
So they compromised and
moved me to California
where my family is.
- [Mark] And where do you sleep?
- On the streets.
- [Mark] You're just on the street?
And so tell me about your childhood.
- I was spoiled.
I had the best childhood ever.
We went on vacations.
I wasn't too cold, it was great.
I was spoiled when I was a kid.
- [Mark] So great childhood.
- Yeah, but I became,
I felt like the black sheep of the family
and I taught myself the street life
and I did street life.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- I taught myself the streets,
living on the streets by myself
'cause I felt like left out a little bit.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- I don't know, because I was the baby,
I always got picked on
at school and I was-
- [Mark] Why were you picked on in school?
- I was in special ed.
I was like always behind and I was-
- [Mark] Oh, you were in special ed?
- Because of my voice
my dad would pick on me,
said names about my voice.
- [Mark] So the red mark on your face-
- I was born with it.
- [Mark] You were born with it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And people would
pick on you for that?
- Yes, they would.
Called me pepperoni face, scar face,
all the (indistinct), I felt like
the black sheep of the family
so I did the street life when I was,
started when I was 20, 21 years old.
Yeah, but I lived with
my mom till I was 20.
I started on crystal meth
and I moved to crack cocaine.
- [Mark] So you started with crystal meth
and then now you're doing crack?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how long have you
been doing crack, crystal meth?
When did you start with,
drugs, I guess is the question?
- 20, 21 is when I started the crystal.
Then, 2013, I went to crack.
So however many years that is till now
I've been doing crack.
- [Mark] And what do you do for money now?
- Prostitute.
- [Mark] Prostitute.
- But my parents are still there for me.
They still see me once a week.
They bring me clothes,
bring me whatever I need
and still give me my allowance,
'cause I still get two checks.
But they still bring me
allowance once a week, too.
- [Mark] Oh, they do.
- None of these women down here
don't have their parents
because of what they do.
My parents are dedicated.
They used to bring out search parties
to find me, 'cause that's how much they,
'cause I'm the baby and
they didn't wanna...
Because I'm dual diagnosed.
I don't, you know, you feel me.
I was molested by my uncle.
They always say when you were molested
when you're a kid,
you'll automatically do prostitution.
- [Mark] You were molested at what age?
- Eight, seven, eight, nine years old.
- [Mark] By your uncle?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Did you know
anything to tell your mom or?
- I did eventually.
It got worse so I eventually told her
because I was scared
to tell her, you know?
'Cause I don't want her not to have
a relationship with her brother,
you know what I mean?
And it was just hard.
But I don't wanna talk about it.
I have five brothers and one sister
and I make seven, so five
brothers, two sisters,
one sister, so that's seven of us.
I have nine nieces and nephews
that I only met two of them
when they were a baby
and they're almost six,
seven, eight years old now.
- [Mark] Do you have any children?
- [Jamie] No, I was pregnant
four different times
in two years.
- [Mark] And what happened?
- [Jamie] I got abortions
and one miscarriage.
'Cause my mom is not
letting me having a baby.
I am not responsible enough,
'cause I have a child, I'm not responsible
to raise a child, especially when I live
on the streets like this.
- [Mark] Yeah. Do you
use condoms when you're?
- [Jamie] Yes, I do.
I get checked every three months.
I was always negative.
But I have good genes
throughout my family.
So we never had...
We were always healthy.
My grammy was 97 years old.
Still cooked, still cleaned herself.
Never uses a walker or cane
or a wheelchair or whatever.
And she always complains
about her eyesight.
She never learned how to drive or swim
and she was 97 years old,
still cooking and cleaning for herself.
Never complained but her eyesight.
My mom's very energetic.
My mom doesn't use look her age,
my grandma doesn't look her age.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I just turned 34.
- [Mark] You look pretty good, too.
It's dangerous here with
picking up guys on the street.
- No, it's not-
- [Mark] Do you have
crazy stories to tell.
- I had some tragic ones,
but it wasn't that tragic.
- [Mark] What happened?
- They would drive, they would tell me,
throw my like a football, beat me up
and tell me I'm gonna take my money back
and then one guy like we-
- [Mark] Wait, throw you out of the car?
- No, like this, throw me against the car
because rape is coming.
- [Mark] Oh, they're
raping you rather than-
- Yeah, they raped me
and I didn't like what they were doing
so they just threw me and take my money
and their money, you know what I mean.
And like this one guy,
I was trying to get out screaming help,
trying to get one or two people's help
that was on the streets, their attention,
and he drove 65, 75 on like
a 20, 15, 20-mile speed limit zone.
I had to open the car
and I had to literally
get out doing that speed
because he was literally hurting me.
Yeah.
And I had twice a gun pulled on me
and one a gunshot, a
bullet went right past me
and a knife pulled, all that stuff,
but I just passed through it.
It wasn't-
- [Mark] Jamie, thank you
so much to talking to me.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] For sharing your story.
- No problem.
It's a little bit of more
story, but a lot more,
we don't have the time today.
- [Mark] You got more to tell.
- [Jamie] Yeah.